from the very
beginning of this
war in ukraine
we have
strongly condemned this act of
war
the situation
is not getting better unfortunately it's
a tragedy for for ukraine for the people
of ukraine
but it's very challenging and difficult
times for the whole
neighborhood and europe and world
what i can tell you is that the belarus
ambassador to moldova was summoned to
the foreign ministry
by a state secretary which is the level
of deputy foreign minister and he was
asked about clarifications on the issue
from what i understand the the
ambassador said that there was a mistake
on behalf of the
ministry of defense of
of belarus
in a way
saying that this was not the case we are
very concerned uh
with this situation we condemn this
and one cannot be sure hundred percent
of
the next
phase
will we be targeted or not
as of today
it seems that we are not a target
but what happens in a week's time
i cannot predict
we are very vigilant we are very
concerned there is an emergency
situation all over the country following
the broke uh the the the the conflict
that broke out in ukraine so basically
the whole
uh institutions and countries are on one
alert these days we are in talking in
talks with with a lot of our partners
and receiving
a lot of high-level visitors these days
in moldova
but
of course
the country is prepared to any kind of
scenarios including the very
the very worst case scenario so we will
be
defending what's to be defended of
course i think the the armed forces are
well prepared our assessment is that
there is no
threat
imminent threat of escalation on their
behalf
but of course one shouldn't rule out
anything
given the unfolding
circumstances and conflict in the
regions we are not seeking a nato
membership because we are neutral
but we are seeking membership to the
european union and this is the choice of
the people and we want to develop our
country as as an independent country
with our own
flag and anthem we don't want to be
under other flags people from moldova of
ukrainian origin
but also from the west they are
traveling
to ukraine
to defend their country their
motherland this is so impressive and
this tells you a lot about the
patriotism and about the wish of the
people to have their own
country
flag anthem